Mark Margolis was a character actor of
the highest degree bringing gravitas to
any role he was in no matter how small
that Talent gave him Legions of fans and
numerous people mourned the actor when
news of his death broke Margolis died on
August 3rd at the age of 83 leaving
behind a Monumental body of work with
more than 150 credits to his name from
Scarface to six Darren Aronofsky films
Margolis touched the lives of many but
arguably his most recognizable role came
in the form of Hector Salamanca from
Breaking Bad and Better Call Saul
Hector was incapacitated throughout the
present-day timeline of Breaking Bad
only able to communicate with facial
expressions and his iconic Bell still
Margolis received an Emmy nomination for
his work in season 4's finale Face-Off
Margolis reprized the character for the
prequel series Better Call Saul where
audiences could see what Hector was up
to before using a wheelchair
die for this for playing one of the most
memorable characters in modern TV
history it should come as no surprise
that many actors and crew members
Margolis worked with on both series have
posted tributes to the actor in the wake
of his death Dean Norris who played Hank
Schrader on Breaking Bad was one of the
first to express his condolences on
Twitter posting so sad to hear Mark
Margolis has died a phenomenal actor a
funny guy R.I.P my thoughts are with his
family Breaking Bad writer Peter gold
also expressed his sadness writing
absolutely devastated to hear that we've
lost Mark Margolis Mark was brilliant
funny a rock and tour with a million
stories I miss him already both Breaking
Bad and Better Call Saul had their
lighter moments but they could be dour
dramas when they wanted it's only
natural for the cast and crew to find
moments of levity when the cameras
aren't rolling and Bob Odenkirk who
played unscrupulous lawyer saw Goodman
on both series remembered just how funny
Margolis could be and given Odin Kirk's
comedy background that's really saying
something Odin Kirk wrote a powerful
screen presence Mark made me laugh in
the van on the way to set with his jokes
and comments and I only hope I have half
his energy and focus when action was
shouted thank you Mark and condolences
to your family of course margolis's
contributions to the world of Breaking
Bad are all thanks to casting director
Sharon bialy in an interview with gold
Derby she talked about how the actor was
her favorite scoop for Breaking Bad and
she detailed asking him to send in a
tape even though Hector Salamanca didn't
have any lines she also took to Twitter
to look back fondly on his career
posting R.I.P to a true professional and
Gem of a man he was superb and Better
Call Saul and Breaking Bad he was a
sweetheart and a great actor I will miss
him Margolis proved how an actor could
do a lot with a little Hector Salamanca
was an obvious force to be reckoned with
and Breaking Bad and Better Call Saul
which isn't an easy feat when he
couldn't talk for most of it he even
helped Inspire the next generation of
actors as Luis mancata who played made
one of the nefarious twins Marco posted
he was a Class Act old school guy no BS
attitude and very funny we spent a lot
of time with him he would tell us
stories about his early days in NY great
times I'll always remember our
conversations my friend Max arceonega
also chimed in with his thoughts he
played Crazy 8 on both series and
expressed his appreciation for getting
to work with Margolis posting it was an
honor to have shared the screen with
this Powerhouse and an honor to listen
to the stories he shared about his
family and his career rest easy Don
Hector Margolis was a consummate
professional delivering an
emmy-nominated performance with nothing
but a look of determination and ringing
a bell over a career that spanned
decades he worked with many artists and
touched the lives of countless fans
foreign